politics few would disagree that we are
living in divided times the gap between
competing visions of the future and our
very identity as a nation have never
been greater so what better solution to
heal this toxic atmosphere not to
mention these times of austerity than a
new 300 thousand pound statue of
Margaret Thatcher yes I am being serious
the most divisive political leader in
generations
is about to be commemorated with a new
bronze monument in her hometown of
Grantham in Lincolnshire those who have
followed my work know that I'm no fan of
statues this particular sculpture was
already rejected by Westminster Council
in London because of its magnetic appeal
to protesters and vandals I don't
condone crime but I also don't
underestimate how strongly people feel
about the harm done by mrs. Thatcher
whose policies set this country on a
path to being one of the most unequal in
the developed world why not use the
money to help those who are still
struggling to cope with her legacy
instead Thatcher must fall panel ok
effort mrs. Thatcher Margaret Thatcher
of blessed memory yes it was our first
female prime minister loved her or loved
her she has an absolute right to be
honored with a statue in her hometown of
Grantham I cannot I mean given the
paucity of female role models the
paucity of statues representing actual
historic female figures not to have a
statue of mrs. Thatcher would be an
absolute outrage well sing well so
that's the best not because she's a
woman women should veneration
women she did more to harm equality than
any other leader in my life all know
that she saved the economy no you don't
think so this idea let me show you let
me show you it's that about the personal
cost people and low-income the working
class teacher I've got a stack view
three million workers were unemployed
while mrs. Thatcher was Prime Minister
and during her time in office over one
hundred eighty seven thousand miners
went on strike because of cuts she
created the nearly let the destruction
of banking reforms that helped create
the credit crisis she helped him that
has made a funny there are so many of
our current problems I'll have a quote
for counsel of one well you can say that
she did anything decent
I'm not did she do anything decent did
she do well anything I'm not a fan of
yes no yes you did throw no she didn't
did she doing it if you ask me what
might be of her legacy as I'd say is a
negative and destructive so she did do
innovation salute the more we talk about
if we just like peace through her legacy
yes she did some good things yes she did
some bad things we have the council
leader saying that they're gonna have to
police the statue as a result of
everybody just deciding if somebody
wasn't 100 percent perfect in everything
they did they don't deserve and to have
a statue because they're from the lady
from the council please our police are
struggling to manage without the
additional burden of policing a statue
that has potential to be vandalized I
understand my Margaret Thatcher's statue
is currently out of sight in a secret
location perhaps it should stay that I
understand that they're going to have to
clarify that's the labor leader leaders
occasion just said clarify that only
they Rachel yeah I think just think it's
sad that we live in a society whereby
you know people's statues or we've seen
war memorials being vandalized we've
seen Karl Marx's statue being vandalized
nobody is perfect
so everybody is is up for grabs good
people others as well Nelson
not the top of the column but the one in
Parliament's were Nelson Mandela he's
got a statue all right yeah
he was a convicted terrorist and I take
back what I just said about you because
I agree with you I agree with you on
this topic yeah let me just show you the
number by the way of male versus female
statues in the UK just as an interesting
points the 550 for male statues in the
UK and when it comes to women 174 so I
just want to correct you because you
made a statement that actually when
Rachel said about maggot fact being a
role model you said she's not a role
model to women so I want to correct you
because actually she is quite a role
model to me and the reason yeah but you
made a sweeping statement saying I will
not assume she's a role model for all
women just because she's alone because
what she and other people like her
because I really do believe that I can
achieve anything that I won I don't
believe if my gender holds me back you
might call it deluded but I don't
believe I like that I can we dilute I
feel like I can do anything and one of
those reasons that I have that belief is
because of people like Margaret factor
what the daughter of a green green
grocer or whatever it was she rose up in
a significantly male-dominated field to
become the very very top of her industry
and field and I respect that she may
have made some ridiculous decisions you
know she did many things that I disagree
with but I'm massively respect the
achievements she made and in this
environment whoa we're constantly
telling little girls you're going to be
discriminated against we must be showing
them areas where they won't be one thing
I can't understand a foot you know how
its funded don't you this day it's
funded by charity and privately fire did
you did mention like use the money you
said somebody's got 300,000 pounds
holder named I can think you said use
the money to address the inequalities
but this is privately would like three
hundred thousand pounds to inspiring
girls for example I can think of that's
why we're having a debate I disagree
you think it's great that's what debates
about I think I represent people who
find her legacies one that is still
painful and feel the intergenerational
British people
living out painful living out what
that's his view and easily he's not
trying to stop a Nelson Monday the
starchiness it is there is there for a
reason is you know we've procedure done
some great I am NOT a fan of the way we
erect statues period because I think it
oversimplifies people's legs complex'
Thatcher is a particular extreme case in
my opinion because we are still dealing
with the fallout of the reforms that she
created this whole brexit movement it
was partly a result of the Euro
skepticism she engendered in the
Conservative Party in the country the
closure of George I wanted Sarah she
sees about any plan as to what would
replace mining an industry in parts of
the North and the South are still what
we are saying is some of the
achievements that she did make in her
life make it I disagree you're entitled
to your view I don't think we should
have a statue of her she's extremely
divisive and there are a lot of people
who feel like me I'm not just some
fringe loony lefty as I'm sure the
Express will report up to having seen
this debate handily feels this way about
and I think it's provocative and if you
look at the comments that the
councillors who backed this statue
some of them have admitted that the only
reason they really want it is to
encourage tourism Jose Grantham know
today there will be a statue of us in
Berkeley Square I was just about to say
for the record
anyone wants to erect a statue of me in
Hall please feel free